All right.
This breaking
news, a deadly explosion
rocks a popular tourist
area of central Istanbul.
That blast in Turkey
captured in this video
posted to social media.
Terrified people
on the busy street immediately
fleeing as you see there.
The governor of Istanbul says
at least six people are dead.
53 more injured.
Let's get right to CNN's
Scott McLean,
who is following the latest deve
How did this happen?
Hey, Fredricka.
Yeah,
so this happened about 3 hours a
now, late afternoon Istanbul tim
Obviously, new information
is still coming in.
This happened on Istiklal Street
The reason that I mentioned
the specific
name of the street
is because if you've ever been
a tourist in
Istanbul, Istanbul,
you have almost certainly
been to this street.
This is the beating heart of Ist
It's a pedestrianized street.
It has shops,
restaurants, bars, galleries,
you name it.
It is popular with tourists.
It's also popular with locals.
And I know
from speaking with my colleague
that the weather today
was absolutely gorgeous.
And so you had a lot of families
out on a Sunday stroll with thei
You had young people sitting at
bars and cafes
and then you had this explosion.
Images shown,
as you can see them
there on Turkish TV
are absolutely horrifying.
A freelance journalist
and witness to this
told CNN that he was in a shop n
from this literally meters,
he believes,
from where the explosion took pl
And when he came out of that sho
he saw people lying on the groun
people bleeding from their arms
and from their legs.
Turkish President Recep Tayyip E
he spoke to reporters today.
The latest numbers, at least six
at least are more than 50 now in
The cause of the explosion is un
but Erdogan called it
an attack, promising
that those responsible
would be identified and punished
Now he is just about to leave
for the G-20 summit in Indonesia
He is still planning to go.
He has been active
in trying
to coax
the Russians
and Ukrainians
back to the negotiating table.
He may now also be there to appe
to Western allies for more help
with security
and in fighting terrorism in his
Of course,
he he stressed that
there is no clear link
at this point between or with te
But he says that local governors
told him that this smells of ter
and that according
to preliminary information,
a woman was somehow involved.
Again, though, that's very preli
at this stage.
One of the thing to mention,
Fredricka, and that is that,
look, Istanbul
is no stranger to terror attacks
It has seen though,
a relative period of calm
for the last five years.
But if you go back to 2010,
there was a terror attack
in Taksim Square,
not far from the Istiklal Street
You've had
a wave of terror attacks
either from ISIS or from Turkish
militant groups
in 2016 and
nightclubs and public squares,
you name it.
And so there's an election
coming up in the country next ye
The economy obviously
has been front and center,
perhaps because of this.
Security will also
be part
of the discussion as well Fredri
Terrible situation
Scott McClain, thanks so much.